[Musique]
toujours pas normal pour l'esprit égyptien
surtout pour les hommes de voir une femme sur un
vélo ils pensent que cette femme a l'air très
sexuelle sur le vélo le salaire une affiche d'
elle sur le blanc est très sexuelle donc ça
donne le droit à  les hommes continuent de la
harceler verbalement et
dans les quartiers pauvres, ils croient
que le vélo briserait votre hymen le
vélo vous donne beaucoup de liberté et
pourquoi les hommes ne peuvent que faire avec et les femmes ne peuvent pas
et ils continuent de me dire que tu dois
accepter  le fait que les femmes ne peuvent pas
tout faire mais non je ne l'accepte pas quand
je vois des femmes faire du vélo je vois le bonheur
dans leurs yeux c'est comme si ça me raffinait
elles peuvent le faire donc et comment
normaliser cela en
s'engageant activement dans les rues  du Caire quand
beaucoup de Mencia font du vélo librement dans la
ville beaucoup leur esprit s'y habituera et
ils penseront que ce n'est pas
[Musique]
quand ce n'est pas le Ramadan nous avons deux
trajets par mois et nous donnons des vêtements nous
donnons des couvertures nous  donner sc  hool
fournitures nous donnons des vivres et des
jouets et cette année nous collaborons
avec d'autres ONG nous voulons faire plus d'
activités plus que simplement donner
les besoins de base nous voulons faire plus que
cela aussi en vélo je veux changer la façon dont les
gens définissent le genre  attentes Je veux
qu'ils s'attendent à ce que tout puisse
être fait par les deux sexes parce que je peux
voir l'espoir que cela change, donc je
poursuis toujours cet espoir
[Applaudissements]